robert in brooklyn new york starts us
off this hour hey robert how are you
good afternoon dave dr john how are you
guys great man
how can we help great great um
about a year ago my father passed away
uh he was my business partner we have
general contracting company
and uh and a very you know and obviously
my best friend as well
and uh we had two properties that we
invested in
uh recently that now i'm half partners
with my mother
by default and i wanted to see what your
guy's opinion on
uh what i should do with them
i'm sorry for your loss um thank you i
appreciate it
is there um okay you and your dad work
together every day
and so yes you could fight things out
you could talk things out for the
business or for the
investments or anything else if you had
a renter problem you just talk it
through
how's it going with your mom
uh essentially i'm doing everything
which is fine she had no involvement
with the business so uh
i just since he passed away i've been
doing everything
do you want to still be in business
talk to john at the conversation for a
different time but that's
that's where i'm at right now i mean i
do i i do enjoy being a general
contractor
it has its ups and downs but um are you
asking
about the are you asking about the
houses what to do with them or
what are what are we trying to get to
here yes
the properties i'm trying to figure out
what i should do with them
okay all right well there's nothing
wrong with you managing them
and owning half with your mom as long as
there's not some kind of toxic
stuff going on it's not putting a strain
on anybody there's also nothing wrong
with you selling both of them and
splitting up the money
give her some money and you take some
money and you can even help her get with
an investment broker and do some
investing
um you know so she's got some of that
money coming in
uh what would she like to do
uh she she's left it in my hands um she
is
on board either way um my father and
mother
they had a great marriage but i never
realized how little
she was involved in the finances so
since
um his passing i've basically had to
give her a crash course on on how
everything gets paid for
you know and my the two properties we
i would say we invested about i would
say six to seven hundred thousand
they make about 90 gross a year and
they're worth about
2 million if you sell them
so in that circle that loops me back to
my question
do you want to keep doing this um
because if your mom's indifferent
and the finances here if you sold these
properties and walked away with it with
a
hefty return on this it sounds like the
real question for you is do you want to
still keep being in this business you're
you're in it with your mom financially
but she's not help coach he's not trying
to jump in and manage it and i think we
should do the lawn this way and
i want to use this roofer and so really
it comes down do you want to do this or
not
there's nothing wrong with either answer
no in terms of the financial or business
aspects of it
since there's no toxicity um it's i i
let me ask you something i think i'm
hearing
a little bit of resentment for her being
what we call in the south a kept
woman she was so taken care of and so in
the dark and she's just like you keep
doing all the work like your daddy did
and just send me the money
yeah it's i mean not exactly in that
sentiment but yeah she's concerned about
me having to take on the burden of
supporting her because i gave her my
father's paycheck for the past year
and everything to kind of get everything
settled but i'm at the point where if i
continue the business
i need to free up that capital to hire
people to help me yeah you know
a very big spot the business is a
separate equation from the real estate
is it not
yes but they're it's their to me they're
intertwined because if i sell it i could
reinvest in my own business
you still have avoided my question what
do you want to do
dr john what am i what do i want to do
what uh what do you want to do with the
real estate
and then what do you want to do with the
business
i know you since i want to keep the real
estate i want to sell
sell it done sell it split the money
with her help her do some investing help
her go through
i'll give you ramsey plus let's put her
through a money course so she learns how
to be a
a person who handles her own funds okay
we'll teach her how to handle money
and i'll pay for it sure i'll take care
of widows here
that's what we christians do and so
we'll do that we'll take care of her
in that regard not by taking care of her
but by showing her how to take care of
herself teaching a fish rather than
giving her fish
and then you she's going to have a
million dollars and then you're going to
use some of this money to buy
her out of your business aren't you
no no she has nothing in the business
it's not to buy her out okay so she
doesn't have any ownership of the
business from the estate
no sir okay sir okay cool sell the real
estate split the money help her get set
up and get running
and you use the money on your side to
run your business is that okay
sure yeah yes does that make you smile
it did yeah it did okay does your dad is
your dad in heaven smiling
uh i hope so yeah i think he is i think
i'm doing good you took care of your mom
and you're running your business
and you're a grown man you're gonna hand
your mom a million dollars robert you
did a good job
you talked you you sat down and taught
your mom how to take care of herself you
gave her
a gift of freedom you're a good son man
you are you're a good man
um you're listen a scum burger wouldn't
be wrestling with these things
no they would have sold the house and
given mom 50 000 and said look at all
this money
right and hey those are the kind of sons
that call my show sometimes dave
like they are out there robert and it's
not you yeah you're a good man
so hold on i'll have kelly pick up and
we'll get your mom signed up for a year
in ramsey plus she can go through
financial peace university she can learn
how to do a budget on every dollar
there'll be coaches in there to help her
uh you can walk with her through the
whole process to ensure that she's
learning the lessons
there's accountability with groups and
coordinators in there it is
ramsey plus is the full package for you
to do the whole thing
and it's going to be free to her okay so
you hold on kelly will pick up
and we'll get that going there's nothing
wrong with starting ramsay plus with a
million dollars
head start right there's nothing wrong
with that at all sitting down with rent
with a smartvestor pro and getting that
money invested what's the best web we
can do
that's right so
if you listen to this show
one of the reasons people listen to show
is entertainment because
humans are just freaking entertaining
but the other thing you
if my challenge to you guys listening is
to do what i've done for 30 years doing
the show and that is what is your
takeaway from some of these things so
here's your takeaway 45 year old couple
both of you need to know how to handle
money
because one of you is not gonna be here
someday that's right
you are not empowered you are not
equipped
you cannot just say it's a famous
southern saying
whatever you wanna do honey no
because one day honey won't be there
you've got to learn how to do this
it is unfair to everyone in the picture
for you to intentionally not know how to
do this stuff and someone else take care
of you
you're grown up busting it mama
this is the ramsay show